How can I help you?
JACOB: I've got an
1894-S Barber dime.
And where did you get this?
JACOB: My wife found
it in the garden,
and I know that it's very rare.
It's the rarest of the rarest.
They call this one
the King of Dimes.
It's one of the most expensive
American coins there is.
[change rattling]
JACOB: In 1894,
the San Francisco
mint printed one of the
most collectible coins
in US currency.
My wife found the coin while
she was weeding the carrots.
I'd like to sell this
coin because it's
worth a lot of money, and I
could pay my house off with it.
This is pretty amazing.
It's debated how many
there are out there.
The rumor is 24.
One of the stories is
that the director of mint
was having a reception or a
party, and he printed 24 dimes,
and handed them out at
gifts at the reception.
Another story is the
mint director gave
some dimes to his daughter.
He told his daughter
to keep them,
they'd be worth a
lot of money one day.
And on the way
home from the mint,
it was a hot day, so she
used one of the times
to buy some ice cream.
[laughter]
[music playing]
If you're gardening and
you find an 1894 S dime,
it's sort of like hitting the
lottery five times in a row.
But not all of them
are accounted for.
So there is a possibility.
So have you had this
checked out by anybody?
JACOB: We had NGC look
at it, but they just said
that the date was hard to read.
OK.
How much you looking
to get for this?
JACOB: I'd like to get $400,000.
$400,000?
JACOB: Mm-hmm.
All right.
So did you clean this?
JACOB: My wife did.
She couldn't read the date.
She couldn't see the
front side of the coin.
So she actually scrubbed
it with a Scotch Brite.
And I jokingly said she
scrubbed $100,000 off the coin.
Yeah.
You have 1, 8, part of
a 9, and nothing else.
There's no way to bring
that date back up.
It's gone forever.
Also, the first ones that
were struck were proofs.
And they were
struck really hard.
This is not struck really hard.
This is not an 1894 S.
OK.
Thanks for coming in, man.
I appreciate it.
JACOB: All right.
Well, thank you.
I wish it was real.
But--
Me, too.
I'm pretty disappointed.
I really thought I
had the real thing.